larundan geraldine is still trying to
pick up belongings from the rubble of
her damaged home
a mother of five she says heavy rains in
chad's capital in germany forced her and
her family to seek shelter when their
roof and walls collapsed
i was in the market and it started
raining heavily then i got a call from
my neighbors that my house was destroyed
luckily my children were not home i came
back to find the situation like this
at least 22 people have been killed by
rains and floods and dozens of others
injured since the start of the season
according to the united nations
across the country over a thousand homes
have been destroyed
many people here say they've not seen
this much rain and destruction before
according to the u.n environmental
agency chad is one of the countries most
affected by climate change and those
likely to suffer as a result are the
vulnerable communities
the floods have left many with no access
to clean water this is one of the main
hospitals in germany now it's surrounded
by flood water
almer
because of the floods patients can't
come to the hospital there is no
transport we only receive severe cases
that are brought here by ambulances
but many of those who are sick can't
come
medical services have also been
disrupted amid concerns of waterborne
diseases
we only have two departments working
the children's department and the
surgery department all the other
departments have stopped working because
of the water in the hospital
the rains are expected to continue until
october and the fear is that until then
more homes will be destroyed more lives
lost heber morgan al jazeera in germany